[Music]
for centuries
we've been fighting and keeping track of
different things that move in and out of
this world
the most dangerous ones we find a way to
contain
this is one of the worst ever
mom can you hear me
i had a man speak with my mother i am a
mother
it's mom the thing that's got a hold of
her it's gotten stronger
this family is unnatural behavior
i've never experienced anything like it
what happened to them it wasn't some
random family tragedy
their father was evil
and mother cursed him for discovering
the truth
there are other forces that play here
the demons are powerful people right not
all of mankind
we can't do this alone should we put
them together now
the will we blow back
please tell me that is dead
you come crawling back
for mommy's love
is a hellstrom family reunion
[Music]
welcome back everyone this is going to
be my new marble hellstrom trailer
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
easter eggs ghost rider
all the really crazy supernatural dark
stuff that marvel was working on in
marvel phase for marvel phase five
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos
we'll do a new amazon giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what kind of really dark
team up you want them to do with
marvel's supernatural characters during
marvel phase 4 marvel phase 5.
so if you don't know what's going on
with hellstrom this is a limited series
it's only going to be one season it's
the final tv show that marvel did
under jeff loeb and marvel tv before
they sort of reorganized things with
kevin feige
and he started pumping out all the
disney plus marvel avengers spin-offs
the show is sort of a cross between
rosemary's baby in the omen series
damon hellstrom is the son of marvel's
version of the devil
so in the series as you can see he's
sort of like a supernatural detective
like john constantine from the dc
universe
and if you haven't spent a lot of time
reading those classic marvel comics that
deal with ghostwriter and their darker
characters
marvel's version of the devil is not
mephisto mephisto is a version
of a marvel devil but he's not the devil
in this context
he's just one of the many different
cosmic fear lords from other dimensions
in the marvel universe we'll get into
that when we start talking about doctor
strange 2 multiverse of madness stuff
the way marvel explains heaven hell is
really just other dimensions
in the marvel universe but there are
different tiers of gods in the marvel
universe like you have the sky fathers
you have people like odin
the way they integrate that into the mcu
is a little bit different than what they
do with those characters in the comics
but it's not quite as complicated as it
seems the doctor strange movies are the
best explanation for that
think multiverse of madness multiverse
alternate dimensions alternate realities
alternate universes but the hellstrom
character does have a deep connection to
dr strange he was a member of his
defenders team at one point he was a
member of the midnight suns which is
where you get into big ghost rider
crossover
the partner that he's talking to in the
trailer footage is his sister
her name is satana i think they just
call her anna during a lot of this
footage
but both he and she have the same type
of divine supernatural magical powers
because of their devil bloodline
marvel's introducing blade into the mcu
vampires doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness is going to be the first real
mcu horror movie they're doing a moon
knight disney plus series he's a really
dark character if you're not familiar
with him
so marvel is just doing a lot more
darker supernatural characters heading
into marvel phase four
and this is just the beginning kevin
feige said way back during marvel phase
one they were looking for a path to a
lot of these darker characters like
blade and ghostwriter but they just
didn't know how to get there until they
did doctor strange and he was the route
to that
the reason why this show went to hulu
instead of disney plus though is because
it was part of a larger ghost rider
supernatural
marvel crossover event that they were
going to build up to a while ago
involving the ghost rider tv show that
they had been developing
that's right there was a ghost rider tv
show that they were almost about to make
with gabrielle luna's version of
ghostwriter from agents of shield
the big crossover event was going to be
their next version of the marvel netflix
defenders team
like with daredevil luke cage jessica
jones iron fist all coming together
although the punisher was part of that
he wasn't really a defender's character
now that disney owns hulu that's just
where a lot of their crazier content
that they don't want to put on disney
plus goes so that's why this super
dark midnight sun style big crossover
event was going to go on that
they were going to call the team up
adventure into fear and it would have
just run for multiple seasons it would
have been the same
model as the marvel netflix shows where
you do individual shows but then they
all cross over in a team up show
some of those shows got cancelled in the
last year because they sort of
reorganized the way they make marvel tv
shows now kevin feige is in charge of
everything creative that marvel does
he's in charge of the tv shows the
movies
and marvel comics if you can believe it
he just has a lot of oversight over
marvel comics it's not like he makes
every single marvel comic book he just
sort of informs
overall direction that they're headed
with that stuff but the idea with giving
him control of all the tv shows is that
there's just a lot more consistency and
a lot more crossover in synergy with the
movies when they say
everything is connected they kind of
started out with agents of shield
now they really mean it now there
actually is genuine crossover like we
just got a wanda vision trailer that is
truly connected to the movies and will
inform marvel phase 4
future movies we'll see those episodes
later this year thankfully
this hellstrom tv show is just one of
the few shows that survived the merger
between marvel tv and marvel studios
when kevin feige took over
so they fired jeff loeb in a lot of the
shows that he was developing they got
rid of
including that gabriel luna robbie reyes
ghost rider tv show from agents of
shield
but the basic premise of the hellstrom
show is they're sort of building it is a
x-file style possession procedural where
they go around
looking at demons that possess people
trying to get rid of them and they find
out that one of the worst demons of all
time
has come to earth again no surprise that
demon winds up being hellstrom's true
father who is the marvel version of the
devil
that's why you see all that footage of
the person sitting in the throne with
blood running down their hand just
implying that he is
king of demons they purposefully hide a
lot of the footage of his face so that
you don't see who it actually is like
they scratch it out in that family
picture there
but the way they talk about the father
during the trailer just implies that at
some point he was banished back to hell
and when they refer to the mother
unleashing something new on the world
again in present day
you start to see all this violence
erupting all these demons proliferating
they're just teasing he has returned to
earth and hellstrom and his sister satan
are going to try and lock him back in
hell he has crazy magical aptitude and
his innate divine power is just immense
so doctor strange at one point actually
considered him
as a potential successor for sorcerer
supreme
they haven't said much about the future
of potential midnight suns or hearts of
darkness crossover on the marvel disney
plush shows but i think a lot of that
will happen
probably after they do the blade movie
they haven't said when that's going to
happen now
and because so many marvel movies have
been delayed in the past year but i
think they'll start talking more about
it when they do the actual moon night
series
there have been a bunch of announcements
about castings for say like she-hulk and
the miss marvel tv show
moon night is gonna happen right after
those originally they were going to
release doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness march 2022
that might get pushed just a little bit
again because they just delayed the
marvel movies
one more time this morning as i'm making
this video there was a big announcement
of course i'll do a separate video about
that
because there's a whole bunch of marvel
news today but i think the really
exciting thing with a marvel horror
stuff that they're doing in the movies
now starting with doctor strange too
is that they brought sam raimi back so
not only is he a notable
spider-man director so sort of bringing
it full circle because kevin feige
himself was a producer on those sam
raimi spider-man films
but he's also a notable horror director
there have been all kinds of rumors
about crazy cameos and alternate
versions of avengers characters there
was even a rumor about an iron man cameo
scene but it was going to be the tom
cruise version of iron man
that marvel was originally going to do
back in the late 90s
no joke before robert downey jr became
iron man in 2008 in that first iron man
movie
marvel tried to make an iron man movie
in the late 90s with tom cruise as tony
stark iron man
because robert downey jr is so fantastic
i think we can say now that that version
probably would have been inferior to
robert downey jr's iron man so i am
happy with the way things wound up
but it would be crazy if that winds up
coming true but it's just a rumor at
this point so if we hear any more news
about crazy cameos from alternate
versions of avengers
of course i'll do a video about it all
the hellstrom episodes are going to
start releasing on october 16th
i don't have big plans to do videos for
weekly episodes but i might do a wrap up
after the series is done
i think the takeaway in all this is just
to get really hyped up about super dark
supernatural characters coming into the
mcu
slowly in other marvel tv news they just
dropped that one division trailer i'll
post a link at the end of this
but they also announced that falcon and
winter soldier had been delayed so i'll
talk more about when
different marvel series and movies are
coming when i do a video either later
tonight or tomorrow so as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel you
should see that when i post it
everyone click here for that full
avengers one division trailer video
and click here for that brand new star
wars the mandalorian season 2
trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys
tonight